or book notes with syndicated columnist
tom philpott it's an hour Tom Philpott
author of glory denied there's a moment
in 1991 were you and Alice and Jim were
all together at a trial what was the
circumstance it was the trial for Jim's
son he had four children Jim jr. was
born the day after he was shot down in
1991 they were both there for a trial
second-degree murder trial and he was
convicted okay who was Jim Jim Thompson
is the longest held prisoner of war in
American history his story has been
largely buried under an avalanche of
tragedy for the last 28 years he's a
stroke victim today he couldn't tell his
own story and i met him in 1984 i got
his permission to tell his own story and
so glory denied is about what he went
through in Vietnam it's also about what
his family went through in Vietnam and
the family together went through after
the war who was Alice Alice was Jim's
wife they had been married 10 years at
the time that Jim was lost in Vietnam
and his captivity began and she they
they met in New Jersey Jim found in the
Army a place where he could realize his
dreams and ambitions but he was swept up
in a war that he had no understanding of
Alice had no understand now if she knew
didn't know where Vietnam was even at
the time he was a sign there it's very
early in the war when he was lost and
the war would affect all their lives
profoundly Jim Thompson was in what
service he was an army captain in
Special Forces he was reluctantly in the
Special Forces most Americans believe
that the special forces are all
volunteers or the time John Kennedy said
let's build them up we've got to fight
communism around the world more
aggressively Jim Thompson was on
recruiting duty perfectly happy
a young army captain and he was
volunteered for Special Forces he
protested that isn't what he wanted to
be in he soon the protest went nowhere
he was assigned to it because the army
needed officers for Special Forces he
was soon swept up in it he's being
trained at the time of 1962 to be
assigned to the Congo he was learning
Lingala and suddenly Vietnam got hot and
his team was told to train for Vietnam
where was he from original in
Bergenfield New Jersey where was Alice
from she was a neighboring town of
Dumont they met on a blind date and they
actually switched partners by the end of
the evening having been attracted to one
another Jim Jim was raised in quite a
bit of poverty and kind of a gray
existence that he had his his parents
were older than other parents of his of
the youth his father was a bus driver
his mother was a homemaker quite
dominated by the father his father was
not a very loving man and didn't give
Jim a lot a whole a lot of aspirations
for bettering himself and but Jim got
that from his mother and from various
teachers that he had in high school how
much education did Jim Thompson and his
wife Alice have just high school they
both graduated from high school gym was
two years ahead of Alice again you say
the longest-serving poww in American
military history right the longest-held
poww in American military history there
may be someone else that we don't know
about but it's unlikely when was he shot
down shut down in March 26 1964 he had
been in Vietnam for three months his
assignment at that time was he was in
charge of a special forces 18 the
a-teams were dispersed throughout
Vietnam and
mission was to to win over the local
populace to train them to fight
infiltration by the Viet Cong coming
down the Ho Chi Minh Trail and supply in
the various cores and there's parts of
South Vietnam Khe Sanh was at that time
it became much more famous in 1968 when
there was a Marine Corps battle there
but at the inn in 1963 when Jim first
arrived there is a very remote outpost
quite a dangerous assignment and his
12-man team was there to Train work with
the nuns who were sort of special forces
from from China to work with the
mountain yards who were the native
population there and to work with South
Vietnamese regular forces that who none
of them were as gung ho as the Americans
he was captured 1964 and released after
nine years when in march 16 1973 so 10
days short of nine years okay just for
purposes after the introduction we
entered in 73 he comes back to the
United States we're talking about 91 his
son standing trial for murder why Jim
jr. was born the day after Jim was shot
down Alice had made a decision about 15
months later to move the family in with
another man to pose as the husband of
this other man to sort of put her life
with Jim Thompson behind her the reason
she did that were numerous but her
support system was breaking down Alice
was the kind of woman who was very
dependent upon her husband there were
some problems in the marriage but
nothing that Jim thought about much
while he was in captivity because he
idolized the marriage in the family that
was his dream to get home but from
Alice's perspective she had suddenly had
when her husband was lost jim was born
then she had three young daughters under
the age of six
she found herself unable to cope for a
time the the the commanding officer at
the base at Fort Bragg where Jim was
assigned to Vietnam was always there a
shoulder for Alice to lean on somebody
providing the support that she need
Alice if you want anything if you want
to go to any social events just let me
know but if you're in the military it's
a transient life and soon after several
months the commanding officer is
reassigned a new commanding officer came
in didn't quite know her story neighbors
would come home from work have warm
reunions that Alice could spy from her
close quarters she lived on base and she
found herself increasingly helpless to
to handle this situation a woman who
helped her out Jean Ledbetter had lost
her husband in Vietnam about six months
later the two of them met and were again
support for each other but Jean soon
learned that her husband had been lost
and that she be moving off post so
another support for Alice was gone Jim
Thompson soon after his capture was
tortured for a statement he didn't write
the statement he signed the statement he
then read the statement a lot of
prisoners of war had been tortured and
had to sign the statements eventually
but unlike them Jim Thompson didn't have
somebody to rely on that he could bounce
off what he had just been through he was
kept in isolation which I'll get into I
hope a little bit later but from the
that statement that Jim had made was
broadcast on Hanoi radio several months
later by the time the that was in
November of 1964 so was six months after
Jim was lost Alice heard news reports of
this but the she said that the army
couldn't provide the tape for she could
never verify whether it was actually her
husband the army had a problem finding
the tape several months later she moved
she made the decision she met an Army
sergeant at a bowling alley who had two
children of his own than he
to raise booked for analysis she'd like
to move off with him and they could be
one family in Massachusetts she made
that decision it would forever affect
her life so let me go quickly though
that jim thompson's in in solitary
confinement where in vietnam jim was
perhaps I should tell you first how he
was captured which is at the a-team they
would be resupplied and receive their
payroll from an Air Force plane that
would fly in periodically and if it had
extra gas aboard one of the team members
would hop aboard to see if they could
see what Vietnam activity was like in
the area Jim Thompson didn't go on those
flights usually it was his operation
sergeant who did but he was on R&R at in
a train on the coast so Jim hopped
aboard and he thought he saw a bridge
that had been newly built and he asked
the pilot and Air Force captain by the
name of Richard Whitesides to fly down
below flight minimums which was a
thousand feet and they were shot out of
the sky whitesides likely was killed
from the weapon small arms fire but he
was certainly lost in the crash jim was
thrown from the crash he had a broken
back he had a wound across his cheek he
had burns on his legs and he was in and
out of consciousness when the Vietcong
picked him up he he was kept for the
next four years in jungle camps
throughout South Vietnam it was really
quite a different existence than the
pilots who eventually were shot down in
the north and captured and all together
they were support group but because jim
was isolated he never had any of that
kind of support structure additionally
he was exposed to so much more
physically than they were up there just
from trying to survive in a jungle
environment how many times you tried us
good he tried to escape five times three
the first three escapes came in that
early after he was able to to build
himself back up a little bit to wat be
able to walk for a time he was moved
from Camp to camp on a stretcher but
eventually he was able to to walk to
shuffle and he would shuffle away from
camp hope
to get all the way away and 443 of these
attempts he would just run into a guard
he would tell the guard that he was
looking to relieve himself and then head
back to camp okay 64 he's in the South
being held by the VC the Viet Cong she
isn't where in her life where she lived
she's living in Hudson Massachusetts
with this army sergeant but before that
what base was young Fort Bragg Fort
Bragg North Carolina where the Special
Forces teams so she moves with you call
him Harold yes not his real name that's
correct and why don't you give his real
name he didn't give his permission and
the publishers suggested that I used
soon so they moved to wear again Hudson
Massachusetts how long do they stay
there for the next seven and a half
years they live together living as
husband and wife living as husband and
wife Alice War ready wedding ring posed
as her husband it is as his wife if
someone asked about her past she would
just say her husband was lost and chief
trying to avoid the conversation he
comes home in 73 right we jump again 291
how did Jim jr. commit murder and where
is he today by the way he has been
paroled he was convicted of
second-degree murder been paroled and
moved on promising with promising Lee
with his life what happened to Jim was
this Jim jr. when his father came home
he was called in the gym was a playful
youngster and when he came home from
school he would play outside he barely
checked in this one particular afternoon
his mother calls him in the family is
sitting around the table he says the
young she says the young Jim Harold is
not your father this man is your father
she pulls out a photograph and says and
he's coming home jim was stunned he
didn't know what to say at that point he
goes back outside to play what affected
Jim Junior's life so much was the
reunion of his parents was a very rocky
affair for the next year and a half that
they lived together because incredibly
when Jim Thompson came back Alice was
there waiting for him at Valley Forge
told him how she had lived her life
invited him to divorce if she'd like or
whether they could try to make a family
of it Jim Thompson had dreamed of being
reunited with his family so he figured
let's give it a go they went up to the
house in Hudson Massachusetts unloaded
the from took the furniture out and
moved on with their lives in the army
but for the next 15 months it was a
terrible existence for the entire family
now Harold was there when they all got
together up there he was one of the
escort officers was also with him and he
said it was the most incredible
tension-filled seen he'd never been a
part of it was almost like Harold
suddenly was this uncle who was just an
observer as they went about picking up
their possessions and putting him in
there now what age would Alice have been
in 73 she was born in 35 so what's that
fortune do a little math here when she
was 38 at that time Harold was how old
he was a few years her senior i believe
and jim thompson was home a few years
her senior about the same he came back
he was 39 right him Tom's so how did
they get to that was it Nashville
courtroom Jim jr. was thrown into this
family and his father this stranger in
charge was suffering not only from the
depression he was trying to repair his
family he was trying to rip van winkle
the army at that point he was trying to
repair his career and he was trying to
reconcile how the country fell about the
the war because what kept him going all
those years was believing to that the
country was supporting his effort and it
was a great shock to him when he first
ran into other Americans as a poww to
learn that there was dissension and when
he got home to have that all confirmed
for him that was very tough and in that
environment he became an alcoholic
perhaps he always was one and if he and
the disease blossom for him he was
suffering from severe depression in need
of some psychiatric counseling at that
time and wasn't wasn't getting a
significant amount and in that
environment Jim jr. was idolized by his
father at first I mean among the four
children only the older daughter had
remembered her father and Jacob Pam and
she kept a copy of his photograph hidden
in her drawer her bureau drawer the
mother allowed her to keep it but jim
thompson's name was not to be mentioned
in that household so the second daughter
Laura grew up believing that she had
asked her mother at one point what
happened to their father and she said he
died of snakebite the two younger
children Ruth and Jim jr. didn't know
they had another father they believe
Harold was her father and so in this
environment when Jim returned ala Pam
his princess suddenly wasn't his
princess any longer she had changed she
had grown from a towhead youngster that
he called princess into this sort of
gangly teenager trying to studious
teenager a bookish and not someone who
found her father to be the prince
charming that he expected to be good
close up as we can of this photograph
and tell us as you look at that top
photograph there who's who's who Jim is
in the middle alice is on his right side
Pam is on the next to Alice Jimmy is
beside his father laura is beside Jimmy
and on the outside is Ruth so murder
where well what I'm trying to explain I
guess brian is the kind of environment
Jim a junior was raised in so after 15
months the family fell apart Jim jr.
went from being this coddled
spoiled you might say nine year old who
was at idolized by his father to one day
his mother comes up while he's visiting
with relatives up in honesdale
Pennsylvania and says your father and I
are getting a divorce it's over he
wouldn't see his father again for years
and years at that point his sisters say
that he shut himself off it was like he
closed down this boy didn't want to be
hurt anymore and it was Jim jr. is a
very good-natured warm fellow but but he
if you can draw him out but he's very
quiet and person and he turned to
alcohol himself in his early teen years
he dropped out of high school it was a
wayward son Alice didn't know quite what
to do with him and he became a truck
driver and he had married and while he
was on the road one one day his well
they had divorced then as a tumultuous
marriage that Jim jr. had when he
returned from the road he had he had
found out that his wife had sold some
two hundred dollar car that he treasured
he went to the Silver Dollar saloon in
Nashville looking for the person that
she had sold it to he was kind of a
rough individual he had been known to
knife folks Jim jr. happened to be that
night with a young lady who was a miner
who had a handgun when this person
threatened him according to the trial
testimony Jim shot him and was found
guilty of second-degree murder what year
would that have been 1991 so they had
the trial right away no I'm sorry the
murder occurred the shooting occurred in
1990 and it was a year later that where
was Jim Thompson in 1990 Jim Thompson
junior senior he was in Nashville he was
in Nashville he lived there he lived
there that's he came back but he was on
the road quite frequently at that time
what was he doing then as a truck driver
no no no no senior oh I'm sorry Jim
Thompson senior
sure by that time was a stroke victim
living by himself down in Key West
Florida didn't have a job then he had
retired on full disability from the from
the Army when did he had the stroke he
had the stroke in 1981 was he married in
1990 he was not what was his
relationship with his son in 1990 they
had been relatively strained Jimmy was a
disappointment for Jim senior because he
hadn't been raised the way he would
prefer table manners well educated will
read that that wasn't the way Jim was
was raised he's a bright guy but he he
was raised in more of a blue-collar
environment where was Alice in 1990 she
was living in Tennessee Alice had
remarried after gym and her divorced and
in fact the this summer they saw and
they will celebrate their 26 wedding
anniversary she found a solid
relationship then and he was what 10
years younger than she is yes that's
right what does she live today she lives
in tennessee I don't say the exact
location to protect her privacy how did
you get into all this and how many years
did you spend on this book I spent
weekends and week weeknights working on
on it for approximately 15 years why
well I at the time I was a writer for
army times and someone said I did a
story about Fred sherry who was a Air
Force prisoner of war who had won an
award from the Air Force because they
didn't look after his finances properly
cherries wife had had a child out of
wedlock by another man actually had it
at an Air Force Hospital there was
evidence that they could have checked up
and found out that she was unfaithful to
him so cherry won an award back and
after the article appeared someone
called me and said if you want to know a
more difficult story a more moving story
than that and you might check into this
particular case i found i was told that
Jim Thompson was long as held prisoner
of war in American history that
surprised me because I had always heard
that
alvarez was long as held teow so I
looked into the Thompson story and then
went down to interview him and I found
someone who had had a stroke in 1981 he
lived out for the past three years at
the time I met him as a stroke victim
down there he he was ambulatory he can
speak in broken phrases he can
understand everything that I said to him
but during our first interview together
jim was very frustrated I wanted him to
tell his story and he could not at some
points it looked like his he was
becoming tearful and for it with his
frustration he gets up he goes over to a
small reel-to-reel tape recorder that he
kept in his living room and he turned it
on and and I heard this vibrant
articulate well educated it seemed well
read at least person talking about his
experience while held captive and he
said listen and I listened and I he
provided me access to all his records
psychiatric health records his
intelligence reports and I interviewed
over the course of the next 15 years 160
people who could tell a slice of jim
thompson's story I want to show the
audience how you've done this we'll get
a close-up of this page and ask you why
I mean for instance but they're going to
see in just a moment is it starts up
there with a letter my darling from I
assume this is one from Alice to her
husband and when he was in Vietnam then
Lindsay car and Frank rose and Eddie
Trent and Lindsay car and George Maloney
it's just one paragraph after another
with people identified what are we
looking at right what we're looking at
is the story being woven by the people
who live the experience each one of them
is telling a little slice of the
Thompson story and what I've done is
edited in a way that their thoughts are
I hope one flowing narrative the reason
I did this and I tried to a few times
the right at narrative is I found this
to be much more honest way to present
the facts of this story if it had been a
single narrator telling the story
everything that occurred would be
filtered through me without the been
fit of the primary person involved being
able to tell that part of his story so
what I found I didn't come to the idea
of using oral history to start but what
I discovered was that I was captivated
by these voices they were more poignant
profound powerful jarring than anything
that I could have written and much more
honest at the same time so I wanted to
tell this story through i chose 90
voices to tell this story and I've woven
them together if I could add one point
here too so you say to yourself well how
did he tell the story of Jim's captivity
well I had the great benefit of being
helped by a senior writer he retired as
the editor of Reader's Digest ken
Tomlinson ken Tomlinson had worked on a
book called poww which was really the
first take and at the time of the The
Reader's Digest project they had
interviewed a slew of prisoners of war
when they first came home and most
prominent them but scores and ken
Tomlinson had sat down a couple of
afternoons with Jim Thompson and some of
that was used in the book poww but there
was this invaluable volume of
manuscripts the Ken Tomlinson gave me
that I was able to use in the same way
that I used all the voices throughout
the book to weave Thompson's story in
there which included as we mentioned the
five escape attempts including an
extraordinary really i think dramatic
escape attempt that he pulled off in
october of 1971 in which he and lou
meyer stayed on the lam for a civilian
poww stayed on the lam for two days but
finally found the jungle impassable had
to come back through the camp and was
captured the other interesting thing
about the story is that it hasn't really
been told before because Thompson has
been a stroke victim when he returned
and after he wasn't able to repair his
family he finally understood that he
wasn't generally regarded as long as
held poww although the army had made
gestures that effect he was in his home
town parade and celebrated in that
regard but the reputation that Alvarez
had established was
very solid one and it was based on his
own heroics his own profile among the
many POWs that were held up north and so
I don't believe he can be faulted for he
was the longest held prisoner of war in
North Vietnam more of our interview with
Tom Philpott in a moment mr. Philpott's
chronicle of Captain Jim Thompson is
only one of nearly 80 stories taken from
the past 15 years of book notes TV
interviews found now in book notes on
American character people politics and
conflict in American history it's
available in bookstores and online now
back to our book notes interview with
tom philpott explain then the ceremony
at the Reagan White House where you've
got six POWs they're getting special
metals tell us what that those were and
why the attorney for Jim Thompson was
arguing about what role Everett Alvarez
would play in that ceremony right
Michael sham wits is a real proponent
advocate for Jim Thompson he's a lawyer
who came to know Jim Thompson after his
stroke so he's always wondered himself
why Jim Thompson wasn't generally
recognized as long as held prisoner of
war in 1988 they decided to cut a metal
that would be cast a metal that would
recognize POWs from our various Wars
Everett Alvarez had worked in the was a
executive in the Reagan administration
of a deputy administrator for department
of veterans affairs and he was invited
to represent the vietnam war pows at
that ceremony this is jim thompson with
his back to us in this photo and at the
time Alvarez knew of this controversy
about he would get he would feel heat
from army veteran saying you're claiming
to be the longest held prisoner of war
in American history and Alvarez would
try to correct the record whenever
could but it was very difficult for
example when the vietnam memorial was
dedicated alvarez was prominent in the
reagan administration was in a part of
the parade shama Whitson on Thompson's
behalf had gone to the directors of that
ceremony and said the give Jim Thompson
a prominent role in this and they said
we've already picked who we were going
to have so he and Thompson were in the
section that they watched the parade and
they heard every Alvarez announced as
long as held prisoner of war in American
history so alvarez was aware of this
situation in the confusion and he wanted
to make sure that Jim was properly
recognized so he said to the Reagan
White House look let two people be
represented and indeed they selected to
POWs from World War two Korea Viet in
Vietnam and Michael sham wet said he
have been embarrassed because he was
saying in effect to the White House
don't let Alvarez it should be Thompson
in this ceremony and it was only later
that he discovered that it was Alvarez
who made sure that Thompson was part of
the ceremony but he was trying to be
advocate for Jim here's another picture
of Jim Thompson with which daughter
that's a that is with Ruth she attended
the white house ceremony and had he had
a stroke at this point yes yes as I say
he's ambulatory still looks pretty good
in a in a uniform and but he's had some
very very difficult years what's the
history of Jim Thompson and his daughter
Ruth it's been quite a rocky in that
rude Ruth loves her dad but she doesn't
like the way she's been treated by him
over the years in that gym is very
particularly since the stroke is very
intolerant of people that don't quite
have his own views about things and he
little flights will upset him a great
deal and so they've
had a very tough time of it and give you
an example again this is to some degree
because Jim is a stroke victim but a
couple of years ago Ruth had sent down a
flower arrangement for her dad at
Christmas time and as she had done for a
number of years because she knew he
liked to entertain well the the
arrangement came with just her husband
Ken and their two children mentioned on
the card he called up frustrated wanting
to know what happened to Ruth was she
injured was she sick had they had a
divorce and he not be aware of it ken
her husband said Jim don't don't worry
about everything's fine Ruth will call
you back well she didn't call back for a
couple of days and Jim hasn't talked to
her for it didn't talk to her for about
a year and a half after that where does
Jim Thompson live today in Key West
Florida was the last time you saw him I
think I saw him probably four or five
years ago do you ever talk to him
anything anyway I've talked to him a
couple of times as the book was in
publication and Jim Jim Thompson i
believe is quite pleased that his story
has gotten out but I don't think he it's
the story he wanted precisely as I was
researching the book Jim had hoped that
it would be about him alone his story in
his heroics and what I found was this
compelling story not only of Jim
Thompson a hero five years in solitary
confinement five escape attempts his
first five years he'd never talked to
another American extraordinary what he
went through and nine years long as held
but what I found was the war had
impacted his family tremendously and
that had to be part of the story and I
didn't think I would have that part of
the story until Alice agreed to tell
what she went through why she went
through she's not asking people to
condone what she did she's just asking
people to understand what did she agree
to talk in 1985 and I
didn't call her up cold I had
interviewed her daughter Laura and she
told me that aspect of the story I said
I need to talk to your mom she said the
only way she said she'll never talk
about her poww year experiences her
experiences while her husband was a poww
but then she said well there's one way
you might be able to approach her and
that's through Ruthie her younger
daughter lived near Alice in Tennessee
so I interviewed Ruthie over the phone
and she she said that she would bring
the issue up with her mom and it was
quite a dramatic scene one Sunday
afternoon at Alice's house where when
they were alone Ruth raised the issue
that someone was writing about her
ex-husband and wanted her side of the
story too Alice was quite upset that
anyone was looking into her life but it
was her current husband who said you
know if you don't tell your story
someone else will and it's best that you
tell it have you talked to any of the
family about the book yes since its come
out yes I've talked to Allison Ruth and
I've heard through shim wits when Jim's
reaction jelly was and what's the
reaction of Alice to the book it's
interesting she said it was marvelous
even though you'll see that it it it's a
very difficult to read for her because
the decision she made while Jim was in a
captive she had tried to get him
declared dead she had denied permission
for the Viva organization which produced
the medals during the war or the risks
of bracelets during the war with the
names of the POWs she had denied them
permission to put Jim's name on there
she had asked the art she told the army
that there would be hell to pay if they
released his name but she says it's
marvelous I think because it's a very
truthful portrayal of what she went
through and her support system
collapsing who gave you her letters to
him Jim did but during my interviews
with Alice I had the letters with me and
I went over the letters with
and she agreed that they could be used
in the early part of the book you have
these letters interspersed well he's in
Vietnam you keep talking about his
experience and you didn't throw a letter
in the middle of it for instance one I'm
looking at from January the third 1964
hi honey it was a beautiful day the
girls all three are in the kitchen
eating popcorn they wanted that as their
treat tonight I called the wives today
mrs. Hoff rose aller Smith we are having
our first coffee here next Tuesday and
every page that you go on there's a
letter like that hi darling your first
letter arrived today and I was so happy
I was almost in tears hi darling another
day gone by about 167 more to go by the
end of the book she's charging him with
being a homosexual how do we go from
this hi darling stuff in these letters
all the way to he's a homosexual and and
she says a lot stronger things well
about him it's a both of them are very
complex characters Alice was raised in
poverty herself she had a very
challenging environment her mother was
unfaithful to her father during World
War Two and they lived in a
boardinghouse her father didn't didn't
need to go to the war he was he was old
enough he was a contractor a plumber
that he could have avoided service but
when Pearl Harbor was bombed he decided
that he would go and he volunteered for
the Seabees and Alice's mother was very
frustrated that she was a seven or eight
years old I guess at that point and he
was leaving her alone she had affairs
well her father while her husband was in
World War two Alice grew up in that sort
of environment with not a whole a great
role model her mother was quite a
vivacious and dated quite a bit and had
different men in her lives Jim Thompson
wasn't his parents were a more solid
marriage but they were a strange couple
themselves and like I say it wasn't a
very loving environment what Alice and
Jim had together they always felt was
pretty good and it was though it was the
war and the separation that began to
unravel the marriage Alice looked at the
flaws in the marriage while he was gone
and said in effect that I need more
supply can't be alone and wait because
he might be lost and I'm getting older
and so forth and I've got these four
children to raise so she made her
decision and she rationalized as best
she could she admits that she live with
a lot of guilt during those years from
Jim's point of view he was he was not a
rigorous kind of soldier he wasn't an
athlete in high school and but what he
what he had during the Vietnam War as
fellow POWs said was he was tough as
nails he had hearts and guts that was it
and he lived on that he's the ultimate
survivor if I hope the book details some
of the tremendous challenges that
physical and mental that he went through
as a poww when he got back in his
marriage dissolved and his trust and
women was affected I think he was
exposed to some homosexuality in fact
that I'm sure it was and he was confused
and I've asked him about that and he
said yes experimentation so her charges
were not I believe in accurate but by
that time all the love was out of their
relationship so you have to put it in
perspective from that where are you from
originally I was raised in camp hill
pennsylvania ever served in the military
I was a Coast Guard I enlisted in the
Coast Guard waiting for Officer
Candidate School right after college and
I spent I had hoped to get a ship i was
assigned instead to headquarters in
public affairs and started writing press
releases after three years it working at
Coast Guard headquarters I went to work
for Army Navy and Air Force Times for
the next 17 years where did you go to
college st. Vincent College in latrobe
pennsylvania why'd you major in
science and today you do what full time
I write a weekly syndicated news column
called military update it covers paying
benefices lifestyle issues changes in
policy that affects the lives of service
people and I syndicate that to daily
newspapers near military bases so that
they can get breaking news that affects
soldiers I hope fast every week can you
make them living doing it yes I have
about 50 client newspapers let me jump
again to a whole different scene he had
the guard time I elbows behind my back
until they touched it can't be done
unless extreme forces applied not let me
read that again I mixed it to mr. period
he had the guard time my elbows behind
my back until they touched it can't be
done in less extreme forces applied they
attached a rope to my elbows and threw
it over a ceiling beam and hoisted me up
this fort has forced my arms back even
farther causing excruciating pain on my
breast bone I felt my chest would split
open thankfully I contracted dysentery
and was extremely weak every time they
tortured me I'd pass out what's that
scene from that's early on in his
captivity in the left in the first
couple of years Jimmy went through some
extreme torture that was a typical kind
of torture that the Vietcong and the
North Vietnamese had done on prisoners
of war but Jim was suffering through it
by himself the worst probably the worst
time for him during his first four years
of isolation in the jungles was he
didn't pay sufficient respect to the
guards so they threw him in a cage that
he describes as about two feet wide two
feet high and five feet long and he laid
on his side for the next four months
they would bring him out of the cage
every once in a while that cage there is
more roomier than what he had
experienced but that's the typical kind
of environment that he was kept in just
bamboo bamboo cage under guard but this
particular stint a four month stint was
unbelievably desolate and in torturous
and so he survived they finally brought
him out and put him in when he would go
from the cage laying on his side for
four months to a room three feet wide by
6 feet long is it felt like the Hilton
to him what was his first attempted
escape he had those three relatively
undramatic escape attempts that I
described earlier where he would walk
away from his guards until other guards
would find him and shoot him back to his
to his camp within his first six months
or so though he had it he kept walking
one day and there was no guard to stop
him and he took off and he was he hid he
ran all day as best he could he was
still injured from his from his crash in
the aircraft but he got to a riverbank
one evening and this evening and he hid
in the brush until he thought it was
dark enough to cross undetected well the
vehicon had engaged the local mountain
yard to look for him and when Jim his
feet went into the to cross the river
the bank on the other side exploded with
mountain yards whooping and hollering
and so forth and soon via con cadre were
there and fired at his feet and he was
recaptured the brutal the brutal
treatment that he received really began
in earnest after that he was he was his
head was slammed on the ground until he
passed out numerous times he was beating
some beaten with clubs and sticks and
it's quite early there's an odd moment
in the book where maybe at valley forge
a psychiatrist broke down and cried when
he's supposed to be helping him because
he looked at his fairy tales that wasn't
that was a companion of his and Jim came
back with Don MacPhail another special
forces a soldier who was also held for a
time in the south and it does sort of
indicate to you I hope what scream
conditions they went through but Don was
captured with other special forces I
think that all of them had died but he
was he was held in brutal captivity he
was think five years
but at one point the Vietcong had pulled
out all of his toenails and fingernails
and he was trying to illustrate for me
the kind of lack of support that they
got from some of the the situation when
they got back the psychiatrist
interviewed him to try to get him to
talk about the experience and he found
that psychiatrist crying at the clubbing
experience for his fingers and toenails
that he gone through it's all this on
audio tape no oh you mean my yes I have
a bag full of transcriptions there are
some characters in the book that I
interviewed over the phone and I have
phone notes from but for all the
principles all my interviews with Jim
Thompson with Alice with the the
daughters are on tape what do you do
with it I'm just gonna hold on to him I
mean is it ever gonna can we ever hear
their voices oh I think that's always a
possibility I haven't had any kind of
Bennett someone approached me about that
but but they tell a powerful story Jim
jr. at one point said I've never talked
to anybody like I had with you and I I
took that as a compliment that I
listened closely to what they had to say
and I hope I Petrelli portrayed
accurately and well what they went
through how many different characters do
you think you've got the book i think
there's about 90 of all those characters
who was the angriest and why i think
would have to be Jim Thompson Jim came
back three things he said kept him alive
in captivity faith in God faith in
country faith in the love of a good
woman when he got back he found
eventually none of that I'll explain the
marriage was nothing as he had expected
he expected that while he was gone they
talked about him all the time they knew
their father they couldn't wait to see
him and the the they wouldn't he
wouldn't be unknown to his children he
they would have shared stories over the
years Pleasant things their experiences
of Christmas together none of that was
there when the other POWs in jim was
released about a month after Edward
Alvarez
as I said in March 73 when they arrived
back in the Philippines each was each of
the POWs was given a file folder in
which it contained love letters report
cards than drawings that the children
had done jim thompson's had a pay stub
and he called Alice from the Philippines
and she said we need to talk when you
get back that's what he confronted when
he got back so he has to be that most
angry in the story but so he lost his
faith in the love of good woman the
country didn't embrace the the warriors
from Vietnam the way Jim had expected at
all he he believed it was all propaganda
while he was five years in isolation
what he was being fed by the his captors
was that the your nation is divided over
this war there's great dissension
there's politicians who are saying stop
the war Jim couldn't believe it until
his fur he met his first Americans than
they said in effect yes that's true
there were characters on your book that
good like him Jim is a very
strong-willed individual he spent five
years in captivity by himself he
probably had a numerous arguments and he
won all of them so by the time he met up
with others who had been captured six
months a year he thought he should lead
them he was put into a situation where
he wasn't with other military people he
was with civilians who were captured
during the Tet Offensive in 68 and these
civilians had been exposed already to
the anti-war protest back home they were
in Vietnam to do a civilian type of job
they weren't the gung-ho militants that
they saw Jim Thompson to be and where as
if they were employees of the Defense
Department he did command them some of
them realized that afterwards but many
of them were contractors working for the
Defense Department and they didn't want
to pay attention to Jim Thompson they
don't want to be organized by Jim
Thompson they didn't want to escape with
him jim was blessed that he had one of
his cellmates was Lou Meyer who was this
tough as nails Navy fireman a veteran
himself who believed Jim Tom
was in charge Lou Meyer was an exercise
fanatic he wanted to stay in shape he
wanted to escape when Jim Thompson and
Lou were together for the first time Jim
jumped this hog Lou exercise & gym jumps
out of his bunk tries to do a single
push up and crashes on his face he
couldn't do it he begins to cry Lou
Meyer stops his exercise program he
decides I'm going to build this guy back
up to keep myself in shape I'll exercise
while Jim is sleeping but otherwise I'll
go along with this pace so the two of
them go through this extraordinary
exercise regimen while he's a captive
Jim probably weighed at his worst part
and probably weighed less than a hundred
pounds he was a soldier when captured of
about a hundred and eighty pounds he was
a skeleton when the first POWs got a
glimpse of him not before any of them
live with him but mike o'connor who was
an Air Force pilot or a Warrant Officer
army pilot was shut down during the Tet
Offensive look through a crack in the
door of his cell and he sees this body
up against the cell doors and he thought
for sure the vehicon were playing a joke
on him that that was a corpse and then
he sees the person wink and move and he
realized that it's a human being and
when other POWs saw him at that time
this is 68 they some of them began to
cry because they said that's a look at
Christmas future that's what we will be
so that's kind of thing that Jim that
was his Nate air when Lou Meyer met him
they were getting better food they were
able to live together support each other
and then they began this regimen that
would build up so that they could escape
together in 1971 we started off talking
about Alice and Harold Harold and Alice
lived together for seven and a half
years whatever where's Harold today I'm
not sure where he is I was able to
contact him in the mid-80s to see if he
would agree to be interviewed and he
declined one of the interesting aspects
of the story is that he helped raise
these children none of them ever had any
further contact with them once they're
real father came home analysts never had
any further contact with
so he became a great unknown then for
the rest of his life in their life what
would you say the relationship of all
the children are with Jim Thompson today
very strained I'd say the children would
like to have a relationship with their
father Jim doesn't want them to choose i
believe between the mother and him and
they're not about to make that choice he
remarried yes how did that happen and
are they still married no Jim and Alice
divorces I said 15 months after he got
home they eat soon remarried probably
within six months Jim remarried a air
force officer who actually outranked him
and each had their own way of living it
was a very difficult time jim was
fighting alcoholism and depression at
the time I was originally going to title
the book dream house and the reason was
the way Jim kept his sanity in captivity
was building a dream house over and over
again in his mind when he got home he
built that dream house not physically
but he found the house of his dreams he
put in it what he expected to always put
in it furnished it the way he wanted had
the rooms for his children that he
wanted and the final straw for him when
he got back the final anchor that was
uprooted for him was the his second wife
had changed that house around on him and
believing that Jim may have had adding
may have had some homosexual
relationships at one point she left and
in Jim's mine destroyed that home you've
got some other photos in the book what's
this photo from up here on top on the
flight out of Vietnam another special
forces a soldier Lonnie Smith presents
gym with his green beret what about
below that that is a gym being greeted
at the Philippine Air Base by the
ranking officer Admiral zomo whistling
no it's not it's another animal I'm
sorry I kids looking from the side and
over here what's this photo that is
Jim Thompson went to Valley Forge
hospital to recuperate that's where
Alice met him he said where are the
children she said they're coming down
the next day he had never seen his son
the scene that that portrays is on
either side of him or parts of the
hospital and they were filled with
workers from the hospital watching the
reunion of a nine-year-old boy and the
father he has never seen and Jimmy ran
up the ramp and knocked his father down
he was Jim was very weak the daughters
commented on how skinny his neck was
when they put their arms around it they
they were stunned by that but at that
moment Alice said I've just I decided to
give the family a chance by living with
Jim and seeing if we could repair our
marriage how many other stories not met
that they're just like this do you think
there are the POWs I think this story is
unique in that it goes behind the scenes
it's almost like the underbelly of the
stockdale story where you had a wife who
built an organization while i was in
captivity and and kept the fires burning
and and they had a strong marriage which
continues to this day I think perhaps a
more common story was a prisoner of war
coming back expecting things to be
exactly the way he had left it finding a
woman who had learned to live on her own
to raise the family in a certain way who
wasn't ready to give up her independence
and then I'm talking there if you if
they were nevertheless had waited they
still had difficulty adjusting because
they were had gone on different past or
in the captivity an awful lot of the
POWs ended their marriages their
marriage and it's a few years after they
returned how did you get John McCain to
do the introductions I had interviewed
Senator McCain for the book because a
year after they were the POWs were
released some of the more prominent were
invited back South Vietnam was
struggling to remain a free country they
wanted some publicity they also wanted
to honor the POWs who would sacrifice so
much so McCain and Jim Thompson were
among
those honored they met at that point
Senator McCain knew about the book I
think although he may have forgotten it
by the time I finally got around to
finding a publisher and I sent the
manuscript to him I heard back from his
aide saying that the center gets a lot
of requests to do forwards but he
certainly wanted to do this one for Jim
Thompson toughest part of this book for
you the toughest part was confronting
Jim and Alice with what each of their
stories were and the interesting thing
is that they all they agreed with each
other's facts to a large extent except
that their perception of the marriage
was different a lasting moment that
you'll remember along the way over the
15 years did you put this together
I had many of them actually I was quite
moved by the whole thing but there are
two pet there are two scenes in in the
book that gripped me one is that this
description of a minor character in the
book of a woman who's going to see Jim
Thompson while he's in the Philippines
or Hawaii rather before he goes home and
she's walking down this corridor that is
filled with letters from school children
that have been attached to the wall and
and the moment that she describes that
moves her enormously there I think says
a lot of what the POWs in general
sacrificed the other scene that's quite
memorable for me is when Jimin and done
McPhail first get home and freedom and
they hear a god Bless America plane they
broke down this is the book it's called
glory denied it's all about Jim Thompson
the longest-held American prisoner of
war in US history by our author Tom
Philpott thank you very much for joining
us thank you Brian glory denied is
published by Grove Press visit Grove
Atlantic com for more information Tom
philpotts chronicle of Captain Jim
Thompson is only one of nearly 80
stories taken from the past 15